tonight a little bit about our author
Ethan Rarick as a journalist
Ethan Rarick has covered politics in
both Oregon and California for more than
15 years writing for many publications
including The Associated Press United
Press International the Los Angeles
Times the San Francisco Chronicle and
the Contra Costa Times
he's currently acting director of the
Center on politics at the University of
California at Berkeley and a former
knight-ridder visiting media fellow at
Duke University while covering the 1998
gubernatorial race he noticed that
almost all the candidates cited Pat
Brown as a model governor curious about
Brown Browns new iconic status in
California politics he began the
research that has now resulted in the
publication of California rising the
book has been described as colorful and
masterful by the LA Times shrewd by the
economists first-rate and excellent by
the San Francisco Chronicle and lively
fast-paced critical and fully informed
by Publishers Weekly please join me
tonight in welcoming Ethan R Eric
thank you very much Diane and I want to
thank the the Commonwealth club and its
members for having me tonight it's an
honor to be here as Diane mentioned what
first interested me in Pat Brown's story
and his era was the degree to which he
has experienced a kind of renewed
popularity in the last 10 years and
especially in the last few years I first
noticed that as Diane mentioned in 1998
when I was working as a newspaper
reporter covering the governor's race
the race in which Gray Davis was elected
defeating as you will remember dan
Lungren the Republican and I noticed in
the primary that almost all of the major
candidates including Davis including
Lungren a very conservative Republican
would cite Pat as the model of the
governor they wanted to be and I became
curious about why that was here was a
guy who'd been booted out of office 30
years earlier in 1966 in a landslide
losing by a million votes and by 1998
he's become an iconic figure in
California history and I wanted to think
about why that was and I thought I
should write a newspaper piece about it
and so I called Kevin Starr then the
state librarian and somebody that many
of you probably know or whose works
you've read and I said Kevin what's the
best Pat Brown biography I want to bone
up a little bit in order to write about
this era and he said there isn't one
we're all waiting for somebody to write
one
so I began researching this era I went
ahead and I wrote the newspaper piece
and I continued with the research and
seven years later I have a book and as I
thought about and researched why Pat has
had this transformation of image why he
is now so popular I came to the
conclusion that there are a variety of
reasons some of them relatively small
one of them quite major and touching on
the way that I think California is
viewed in American history
California's view
not only by Californians but by
Americans let me talk first about a
couple of the relatively minor issues if
you will one is simply nostalgia people
now look back at Pat Sarah fondly it's
because they remember it nostalgic Lee
this was an era in which many people
came to California there are a lot of
people who are still in California who
came here during that period of time it
was a new and exciting place to live and
they simply remember that time fondly
because it was their new place to come
to one reason is that the state seems to
be facing some of the same problems now
as we did then in that era we were
facing a huge wave of new population
growth infrastructure was beginning to
break down again those same challenges
exist today but I came to believe that
there was something deeper in the way
that both Californians and Americans
more broadly think about California
today it's commonplace to say that
California is the proving ground of the
American future it's the place where
things happen first things happen here
and are then exported to the rest of the
country the tax revolt of proposition 13
a greater openness on social issues like
gay rights the digital revolution of
Silicon Valley all these things begin
here and move to the rest of the country
but if you read what was written about
California in the century after the gold
rush roughly 1850 to 1950 it's a much
different picture California is
portrayed not as the cutting edge of the
American experience but is totally
outside of the American experience its
distant geographically but it's also
different economically culturally
linguistically Carrie McWilliams a great
California writer perhaps the greatest
writer about California issues wrote a
book in 1949 assessing the California
experience and he concluded that
California was as he titled the book the
great exception California wasn't
typical of the American experience it
was the exception to the American
experience
so why this change why have people gone
from seeing California as being outside
of the American experience to being the
leading edge of the American experience
well I think that the turning point was
the era in which Pat was governor the
50s and the 60s
and I think that people began to think
about California differently because in
that time California typify door led the
way in three great waves or three great
phenomena of American history that then
moved to the rest of the country and
people began to see California as
setting the pace and in each of these
three things Pat is integral to those
stories and those experiences are
integral to his career the first is the
kind of thing for which we remember Pat
most vividly and that is post-war
optimism growth energy in the wake of
World War two the entire country was an
optimistic and growing place but nowhere
was that more true than in California in
1959 when Pat became governor the state
was growing by about 500,000 residents a
year that's about one new person a
minute coming to the state and it was
finally about to surpass New York and
become the most populous state in the
nation that was a moment of great
significance and great symbolism it
wasn't just a triumph of demography but
it was California surpassing New York
even more it was the West surpassing the
East the new surpassing the old
there were lots of symbols of that kind
of thing one of them may sound a little
trivial but one of them was that in 1958
when Pat was elected governor to major
league baseball teams the Dodgers and
the Giants left New York the
self-proclaimed capital of the world to
come to California in the same year
those kinds of symbols showed people
that California was the most energetic
the most optimistic was the center of
American growth and Pat loved that he
loved the fact that his state was
finally about to surpass New York to
conquer New York demographers told him
that that was going to happen in late
1962 and he declared a state holiday for
for celebrations gave state workers an
extra day off called it California first
two days and when the demographers said
well actually it's really not going to
happen as early
is bad you've probably jumped the gun a
little bit it's really gonna happen in
1964 there abouts he said well I don't
care we're gonna have a state holiday
anyway and went ahead and did so and he
used his time as governor to enact a
series of public policies that made
California seem even more optimistic
even more energetic even more the place
to come to to live the good life of
America some of these things are now
widely remembered and they're the things
that we think about when we think about
Pat Brown the state water project for
instance dams the Feather River in the
north of California and then channels
the water through a man-made artificial
river about five hundred miles to the
south so that it can be used for farms
in the San Joaquin Valley and pumped
over the Tehachapi Stu cities in
Southern California the state master
plan for higher education laid out a an
orderly system of growth for public
colleges and universities and provided
that there would be a place for every
graduating senior in public college and
university but there are a variety of
other things that I think people
remember less these days state aid for
education was increased disability
benefits were increased workers
compensation was lengthened air quality
standards were implemented for the first
time consumer protection laws were
strengthened the first major bill Pat's
first term created the Fair Employment
Practices Commission to ban racial
discrimination in hiring the first bill
of his second term strengthened state
laws against racial discrimination in
housing again and again in other words
Pat and those around him used public
policy used their time in power to
implement a set of policies that made
California seem as if it were the very
best of a very good time in America if
America in a tiara offered the good life
California offered an even better
version of the good life so America so
California typifies this kind of
post-war growth an optimism that really
lasted through Pat's first term in many
ways and the second of these great
phenomena American history that I see in
this era begins in Pat's second term and
that is the 60s
the sixties not as a chronological
decade but as an era really in a lot of
ways begins here in California just
across the bay in Berkeley with the Free
Speech Movement in the fall of 1964 when
students at Berkeley begin protesting
against restrictions on speech on
University of California campuses it
sounds strange but at the time the
University of California prohibited
political speech on any of its campuses
it could get almost silly at times you
could have a politician speak from just
off campus to a crowd that was on campus
so people would bring in flatbed trucks
and set up loudspeakers and you'd stand
on the truck and speak to students on
campus but you couldn't set foot on
campus if you were engaged in political
speech Adlai Stevenson gave a speech
like that when he was running for
president the students began to object
to that and to protest it and argue that
the constitutional guarantee of free
speech should apply off campus as
equally a shirt apply on campus rather
equally as it did off campus the protest
through the fall of 1964 became
increasingly confrontational eventually
there was a large sit-in at Sproul Hall
the university's main Administration
Building the police went in more than
800 students and other protesters are
arrested and this really sets the tone
for the era of youthful protest and
rebellion that followed the students of
the Free Speech Movement were inspired
by the civil rights movement in the
south and many of them had worked in the
civil rights movement but the Free
Speech Movement transforms that kind of
demonstration and protest into a more
generalized youth protest against all
forms of authority and it really sets
the pattern in my view for what happens
later in the 60s a few months later in
Los Angeles in August of 1965 a young
man Marcus fries pulled over for drunken
driving a scuffle breaks out between the
police officers and mr. Frey and some
other people who had gathered eventually
this erupts into rock-throwing
eventually that turns into a full-scale
riot and the Watts section of Los
Angeles burns for five days 34 people
are killed more than a thousand are in
our
are arrested more than four thousand are
injured the National Guard finally has
to be called out to restore order in Los
Angeles and again this sort of sets the
tone for what comes later in the 60s
there had been some urban protests in
1964 but nothing on this scale and the
Watts riot sets the tone for major urban
rebellions that followed two years later
both Newark and Detroit experienced
similar things in each of these cases
Pat is very central to the story in the
case of the Free Speech Movement on the
night of the culminating sit-in at
sprout Hall he wasn't even in Berkeley
he was in Los Angeles attending a
fundraiser for seniors cedars-sinai
Medical Center but he was reached by
phone by the local CHP commander on the
scene the protestors were so numerous
that the Berkeley Police Department and
the Alameda County Sheriff's Department
were overwhelmed and they needed the
manpower of the CHP if they were going
to go in and arrest people
so the CHP commander called Pat he
didn't want to go onto campus without
the approval of the governor he called
Pat and said governor these people are
trespassing which was true the building
had closed I want to arrest them they're
breaking the law I want you to authorize
it and Pat said yes his view was that he
had always been sort of a law-and-order
man he'd been District Attorney in San
Francisco and he thought that if people
were violating the law and a local
police officer asked at the scene asked
the governor to enforce the law he
really had no choice but to say yes and
then he went further by announcing that
he had done this there are other
politicians who might have done
something different I think you could
imagine Lyndon Johnson ordering these
arrests and then denying that he had
anything to do with it but that wasn't
Pat's style Pat put out a press release
saying it's my decision it's my
responsibility I ordered these arrests
and so Pat becomes the face of the
crackdown on these students and becomes
centrally connected to the Free Speech
Movement so - in the Watts riot again by
weird happenstance he was not present
when this happened he was actually out
of the state on that occasion out of the
country even he was in Greece but as the
thing blew up he was reached by phone he
immediately began trying to return to
the state
which took a lot longer than than it
does today at one point the Air Force
put him in a jet to fly him across
country and a fighter to get him back
here quicker by phone he essentially
instructed the Lieutenant Governor to
call out the National Guard and once he
got here he again became very much the
public face of the reaction to the Watts
Riots he went any toward watts very
publicly something that no high-ranking
city official in Los Angeles had done he
appointed a very high-level and
high-profile Commission to examine the
reasons for this rebellion in watts he
suggested that the state would pursue
policies that would not allow this to
happen in the future so he becomes the
public face of the response to the Watts
Riots so California really in my view
bequeath to the nation the mood of the
60s and again it's centrally connected
to Pat and then the third of these
phenomena that I see is the conservative
backlash that follows immediately upon
the Watts Riots and is fed in many ways
by the Watts Riots in 1966 when Ronald
Reagan announces he's going to run for
governor he declares that in California
the city streets have become jungle
paths after dark a racially coded
reference to watts that certainly no one
could miss he begins in his stump
speeches to talk about the mess at
Berkeley a reference to the Free Speech
Movement and saying that he will clean
up the mess at Berkeley a line which
connects with audience members in
California and of course Pat is the
target of these attacks in effect he's
running for a third term Reagan is in
essence blaming him for allowing city
streets to become jungle paths for
allowing the mess at Berkeley to occur
so Pat is central to this conservative
backlash by being its victim if you will
it's in 1966 not really in 1980 when he
runs for president but in 1966 when he's
running for governor that Reagan creates
the conservative coalition that
eventually makes him president and that
continues to affect politics in America
so much to this day in the book I
identify 12
blue-collar cities around Los Angeles or
twelve blue-collar cities around the
state most of which are around Los
Angeles the cities with the highest
concentration of blue-collar workers
they're almost all suburbs around Los
Angeles they were almost all suburbs
around Los Angeles filled with
Aeronautics workers blue-collar hard at
shift workers and Aeronautics factories
in 1962 when he ran for re-election
against Richard Nixon Pat carried all 12
of those cities and in 1966 against
Reagan he lost all but one so it's in
1966 running against Pat that Reagan
realizes he can appeal to the people we
now call Reagan Democrats he can peel
away those hardhat workers from the old
New Deal coalition that had governed
American politics for 40 years and he
can create a new conservative coalition
so I believe that in the period of time
that Pat was governor California led the
nation into these three very much
connected and successive waves of
history post-war growth and optimism
sixties rebellion conservative backlash
and those traits of American history
those phenomenon of American history
changed the way that not only
Californians looked at California but
changed the way that Americans look at
California they began to look at it as
the place that sets the tone for the
American future I want to talk a little
bit more before I take questions about
the third of these events of American
history because I think it is the most
important and the one that continues to
affect our society most vividly today
and that is the conservative backlash
people often ask me what's the
difference between Pat Sarah and our era
and there are some obvious technological
differences in social differences but
the greatest difference politically to
me is the degree to which on bedrock
economic issues taxing and spending how
much money we're going to put into the
collective kittie of society and what
we're gonna use it for the political
spectrum has shifted far to the right in
the last 40 years
Pat once said of himself I'm a big
government man and that kind of belief
was central to his career and his life
he'd started off life as a
publican not really I think got a
settled conviction but simply because
everybody in California was then a
Republican even although it sounds
strange to say it even in San Francisco
in the 1920s when he was a young man
virtually everyone was a Republican
California was an overwhelmingly
Republican state there was one session
of the legislature in the 1920s when out
of the 80 seats in the state assembly
Republicans controlled seventy-eight
Democrats held two so everybody was a
Republican and Pat became a Republican
he ran for office the first time as a
Republican he was 23 years old he ran
for the state assembly he didn't know
what he was doing at all in fact his
motto for the campaign was 23 years in
the district that was all he had to brag
about was his age he lost horribly got
out of running for office for 10 years
more or less began to build up the
connections that lead to a political
life but he also experienced an
ideological conversion in the in the
depression he saw the economic
dislocation all around him and he became
very impressed that Franklin Roosevelt
was using government using public policy
as a way to make people's lives better
as a way to help individual people and
so he switched and became a Democrat and
that core belief that government could
be used as a tool to help people in
their everyday lives never left him that
was the central core belief that really
undergirded everything he did and hence
his statement I'm a big government man
well today we rarely hear anyone say I'm
a big government man indeed it was Bill
Clinton a Democrat who said the era of
big government is over Ronald Reagan
said that government is the problem not
the solution many conservatives today go
farther than that and describe
government as a beast that must be
starved
something that Pat would never have
believed or even conceived of to think
about the shift in the political
spectrum to the right on these issues I
think you need nothing more than a sort
of quick and dirty history of California
governors and Taxation when Pat came
into office he faced a large deficit and
he chose to propose and enact a very
large tax increase about 10%
the state budget in today's terms
compared to the state budget now that'd
be raising taxes close to 10 billion
dollars a year
it was focused mostly on affluent people
he raised the upper levels the income
tax and on corporations and he believed
that it was sort of central to his
governorship that if he wanted to fund
an expansion of public enterprise and
public activity he needed to raise taxes
he wrote in his diary I have nothing but
contempt for those who say no new taxes
are necessary and he pushed that program
through the legislature successfully but
it wasn't just Pat Brown he used to do
those kinds of things when Ronald Reagan
came into office he too faced a deficit
mostly because Pat had sort of spent
most of the money on the way out the
door but in any event Ronald Reagan too
faced a deficit he too raised taxes
rather than cut vital programs when Pete
Wilson came into office office he faced
a deficit and although he was dragged
there by a Democratic legislature in the
end he eventually agrees to raise taxes
today Arnold Schwarzenegger comes into
office facing a deficit and thus far
anyway has adamantly refused to consider
any tax increase even at the cost of
suspending the state's minimum funding
for public education now whether you
think Schwarzenegger is right or wrong
about that and I'll be honest I think
he's wrong but whether you think he is
right or wrong that's evidence of how
far on economic issues the spectrum has
shifted to the right and I believe that
that is the great problem in trying to
really understand
Pat's era people today look back at
Pat's era and they remember the
accomplishments building university
campuses building water projects
expanding social programs bursts of
public investment but too often we
celebrate the accomplishments of that
era without really thinking about the
beliefs that underlay those
accomplishments these things didn't
happen by accident
they happen because Pat and those around
him people in the legislature other
elected officials believed in the power
of government to solve problems believe
that it could be a tool for positive
change
they articulated that idea and they used
government and public policy as a way to
solve problems that's why those things
occurred in that era and it's why we
remember that era so positively but
today we see very little of that for 40
years it seems to me we've demonized
government and when you demonize
government for 40 years it becomes very
hard to govern this is not to say that
Pat believed that government should do
everything that it was always right that
it solved every problem nothing like
that and it's not to say that today we
might do exactly the same things in fact
I don't believe we would rather than
build dams and canals we might invest in
conservation projects rather than build
freeways we might invest in mass transit
projects but whatever we do I think that
if we are to try in California and
across the nation to experience another
era like Pat's another burst of public
accomplishment and investment and
achievement we need to move that
spectrum back a little bit towards his
beliefs we need to come back somewhat to
his belief that government can be a
positive force in society can be a
positive agent of change in people's
lives can help to solve some problems
and if we do that I think that
California may once again sort of lead
the nation in a chapter of the American
experience in this case a revitalized
sense of faith in the public sector and
in California we could I hope anyway
experience a period of achievement like
the one that made Pat Brown an icon and
like the one that gave him the sort of
status that launched me on this project
to begin with let me end with that
because I would rather than talk at you
take your questions and hear what you
think and have to say and answer your
questions so feel free to line up Oh
please I was gonna ask you about
Kathleen Browns gubernatorial campaign
but since you mentioned Wilson's tax
increase in 91 or I guess so wherever
that was he came in with a big deficit
and a recession and he put in the nine
in ten and eleven percent bracket with
presumed Democratic support and now when
the recession is far worse than the
deficits far worse the Democrats seem
incapable explaining to the ninety-eight
percent of the people who don't pay it
that they need the revenues to provide
the services which getting cut the
independent legislative analyst says we
need revenues to provide services and
when you talk about the unwillingness to
raise taxes I'm just amazed and
constantly tells the Democrats how can
you not explain to the people that you
need the services ninety eight percent
you don't pay the taxes and they all
seem incompetent and brain-dead well III
don't know if I want to say that people
are incompetent and brain-dead exactly
but I think the Democrats incompetent
the people to but the Democrats don't
know how to explain their own interests
and issues well I think that the reason
that people are reluctant in politics to
talk about tax increases is that as I
say too often for 40 years as a society
collectively we have demonized the
public sector we've said that government
is always the problem that it never does
anything right that it's grossly
inefficient inherently and when you do
that it becomes hard to know why you
should really fund government if you
never talk about the ways in which
government can achieve things can help
people it becomes very hard to justify
politically why you should raise taxes
so I think that there is a nexus between
in Pat's case for instance his ability
to articulate the idea that government
can help improve people's lives and his
ability to enact a tax increase to tell
people we need to pay more into our
collective kittie as I called it in
order to do the important things that
government does you you mentioned
although you didn't ask me about
Kathleen Brown's gubernatorial race and
let me let me tell one story about that
because it's it's a story that Kathleen
told me and it's one of my
favorite stories in the book although it
has no great historical importance by
the time kathleen ran for governor pat
was in his 90s and was beginning to
decline mentally and could no longer
often remember things and kathleen would
go to him she told me and every time she
would go he would ask even when no
campaign was underway what are you
running for and she would say well
there's no campaign right now dad I'm
not running for anything finally she
starts to run for governor every time
she goes she would try to go once a week
even when she was on the campaign trail
he would say what are you running for
finally she had an answer and she would
say I'm running for governor and they
would talk a little bit about the
campaign and how it was going and so
forth the election occurs and as you all
know she lost and lost badly she went
back after the election again as always
he said what are you running for she
said dad I was running for governor but
I lost and she told me that clarity came
into his eyes that she had not seen in
months he suddenly sort of clicked into
the conversation and looked at her
bright eyed and vivid and present and
said by how much and she told him and it
was a lot they were bad figures from her
standpoint and she told him and he said
that's a loss and never again asked her
about politics
let me does anybody else would have
asked him Brown might icon that election
it's been recently said Schwarzenegger
so low but he could come back as Wilson
came back but my take was that Wilson
didn't win that election Kathleen brown
lost achieve he was won in the 30s and
the reason I say she lost it people were
sick of Jerry Brown by that time all she
said is I'm a different shade of brown
and I suggested she could have said I
love my brother but I don't agree with
him on almost anything and so people
were tired of Browns I thought she was a
woman which unfortunately was
detrimental and she was against the
death penalty and so I don't I say she
didn't Wilson
she lost it and I thought if Garamendi
would have won the primary he would have
won the election well you can you can
Monday Morning Quarterback politics
forever and so I don't know what would
have happened if John Garamendi and won
the primary I also I sort of refused to
think that in any political election one
person wins in one person somebody wins
it or loses it it to me it's a teeter
totter and invariably in elections if
you vote for one person in effect you're
voting against the other person so the
answer to your question is I don't know
whether Wilson want it or Kathleen lost
it I don't know that it really matters
what matters is eventually that she lost
she didn't become governor I don't know
that you can really say that you can
credit it to Wilson or blame Kathleen
that was the outcome Andy in politics if
you're gonna run you got to be prepared
to lose Pat was Pat lost a lot and kept
running he lost the first time you ran
for district Ernie lost the first time
you ran for attorney general kept trying
lost the time he saw a third term as
governor so running and losing is a part
of political life yes I wanted to ask
about Jerry Brown you talked about a
backlash to Pat Brown and I was
wondering to what extent do you think
Jerry Brown was influenced to follow his
father's footsteps and to what extent
was he part of a backlash in the latter
context I think for example of building
freeways where Pat Brown was
instrumental in expanding the freeway
system and Jerry Brown decided to stop
that well I think Jerry was was
influenced to follow Pat in answer to
your first question in that he had grown
up in a political household politics was
in his blood that was part and parcel of
his experience in life and so I think
inevitably that sort of is going to
encourage you to follow in the path you
know and certainly it helped Jerry
immensely that his name was Edmund
Gerald Brown jr. he would who knows what
he would have done eventually but he
would never have been elected governor
of the biggest state in the Union when
he was 34 35 were it not for that fact
and Jerry knew that and
knowledge that when he was first elected
to statewide office as Secretary of
State he said at his own swearing-in I
want to thank my mother for naming me
after my father during the campaign I
came to liked that name so he knew and
and paid homage to the fact that his
father's popularity had helped him as
for the question to what degree was
jerry in a way part of her indicative of
a change role that's a great question
Jerry and Pat were very different people
Pat was endlessly affable and outgoing
he would constantly work a room he would
constantly be saying hi to people he
would constantly be interested in what
they were doing where they were from who
they were even years after he was out of
office not running for anything if he
was riding in a car and the car stopped
at a stop sign he'd roll down the window
and say to somebody waiting for the bus
or something hi I'm Pat Brown what's
your name what do you do that was both a
natural trait he was endlessly curious
about people he saw the best in people
he liked people and it was also a
successful political function that's how
in particularly in the era when he began
when politics was hand to hand one vote
at a time that's how he got to know
people Jerry is a very different person
Jerry is more scholarly more bookish but
less affable less outgoing he's just a
very different person than his father
and I talk in the book about a somewhat
tense relationship at times between
Jerry and his dad there are letters in
the book which are I think touching
really in which Pat asks Jerry after
Jerry as governor I wish you would
consult me more on recommending that you
appoint this person or that person I'd
like to talk with you about that
and Jerry generally didn't respond to
those letters didn't consult with his
father I think that's understandable in
a way on both sides on the one hand Pat
very much wanted to be back in the
limelight it was his life and he wanted
to be back in the governor's chair on
the other hand
Jerry wanted to do things his own way so
there was a tension there that I think
one can can understand from both
directions in terms of the politics of
Jerry's well Jerry's fist
conservatism is really what it comes
down to jerry was was also much
different than pat in his ideology and
his political beliefs small is beautiful
was was Jerry Jerry didn't say I'm a big
government man he was about fiscal
conservatism in many ways we remember
the sort of social liberalism and dating
Linda Ronstadt and driving a Plymouth
and that sort of thing but as a fiscal
matter Jerry was much more conservative
than Pat was without sort of getting
into psychobabble which I'm not
qualified to engage in nor do I like I
think there was some element in which
Jerry was trying to differentiate
himself from his dad was trying to be
different than his father and was
pushing back a little bit against a
father with whom he'd sometimes had a
tense relationship and yet at the same
time I think Jerry was also operating in
a very different political environment
Jerry operated after the rise of the
modern conservative movement which
really began as I say with Reagan's
election in 66 and so by the time Jerry
comes into office the political climate
was already in my view on economic
issues becoming more conservative so I
think that influenced Jerry as well I
don't know that even in Jerry's day let
alone today
somebody going around with an ax validly
New Deal sort of philosophy would have
had a great deal of success yeah thanks
the question that I had related to the
changes that have happened since 98 when
you started your book I'm wondering now
what given all the shifts and continued
upheavals in California politics do you
see any legacy among the current
legislators or any current political
leaders and which of those three sort of
significant waves do you see the
influence happening today well the the
the conservative backlash that sort of
killed Pat's career if you will in 1966
continues very much to affect our
politics today it's still the
conservative coalition of Ronald Reagan
that in many respects governs the
country so that's clearly the element of
that
that lives on in terms of politicians
today who mimic pad or who echo pad I
guess would be a better word to use I
think there are a few and I think to be
honest that is in some respects just a
function of the general political
climate as I say it would be very hard
to take Pat's positions on issues such
as taxation the role of government and
succeed with them today even the
Democratic Party has moved well to the
right in the last 20 or 30 years and I
think that until we begin to move that
spectrum back a little bit I think it
will requite there will be required a
sort of cultural or intellectual shift
in the spectrum before politicians can
successfully advocate those kind of
achievements and win having said that
and I and I don't mean this as an
endorsement of him or anything but
having said that there are times when
Phil Angelita the state treasurer talks
about public investment public activity
in a way that you can perhaps see some
echoes of a sort of brownish enthusiasm
for government projects public projects
yeah yes it's 7:15 on kto Georgia Poorna
Stephanopoulos is called be on the radio
and at 8:15 Jerry Brown tonight that's
gonna be on the radio so if anybody
wants to listen to them okay a plug for
George Stephanopoulos and Jerry Brown
they'll each appreciate it I'm sure I'd
like to know how much you consider Pat
Brown's strength in getting his programs
adopted and how much of that success was
related to strong Democrats in the state
legislature I'm thinking of people like
Jesse Unruh and my second question is it
doesn't seem as though a San Francisco
Democrat can get elected to the top two
spots in California anymore and how do
you
I can understand relating that to the
the Reagan Revolution if you want to
call it that but Willie will a San
Francisco
Democrat ever be elected governor or
lieutenant governor again let me take
the the the the second question first I
don't it I mean it goes beyond a San
Francisco Democrat and and this has to
do not only with changing ideology but
with changing geography in California
Pat is the last governor from Northern
California Jerry was born in Northern
California and grew up everybody moved
to LA to start his political career and
all the subsequent governor's to Pat
Ronald Reagan George Deukmejian Pete
Wilson Gray Davis Arnold Schwarzenegger
are all from Southern California and
that in that way Pat's life and career
reflect the changing power of California
when Pat was born San Francisco was
still a bigger metropolitan area than
Los Angeles more important more powerful
during his lifetime Los Angeles
obviously surpassed San Francisco in
terms of its size and power and a deep
pat reflected that and when he got out
of the governor's office he moved to Los
Angeles lived the rest of his life in
Southern California so I think there are
a couple of issues about San Francisco
Democrats one is that San Francisco
Democrats do tend to be more liberal
than Democrats statewide and so that
would work against them in the current
political climate but there's also
something connected to the shifting
geography of California and the fact
that in California that the the
political power has has moved to the
south tell me your first question again
because I Freeman
oh yes ingest son rummy it's a great
question and and much of that success
was due to the work of powerful and
talented allies in the legislature in
particular a general was the Assembly
Speaker for most of the time the Pat was
governor jess was a brilliant
legislative and political tactician
something that Pat was not particularly
good at just was great at counting votes
twisting arms getting a bill through a
committee getting a bill through the
floor that wasn't what Pat was very good
at Pat didn't really have an interest in
that sort of small bore
level of politics he was good at going
out in campaigning meeting people liking
them making them like him
he once said of himself I'm a horse not
a jockey well Jess was a jockey
Jess knew how to ride the horse through
the hole along the rail and enact things
and there's no question that
particularly in the early going which
was the period of greatest political
success for Pat Jess was a crucial and
valuable political ally later as many of
you may know they very much had a
falling out and eventually came to
dislike each other intensely and to be
very bitter Democrats within the
Democratic Party that had something to
do with competing egos it had something
to do with competing staffs the rivalry
was even more intense at the level of
staff it had very much to do with the
fact that Jess believed that path had
promised that he would not run for
governor in 1966 and Jess could run
Pat denied that he'd made that promise
we'll never know there were only three
people involved in that conversation
they're all dead so it's impossible to
say but in any event just thought that
Pat should have stepped aside in 66 and
and and let Jess run so there was a
competition in that sense and there was
also competition in the sense that
Republicans in this area in California
were more or less politically impotent
the Democrats controlled the governor's
chair they controlled almost all the
statewide elected offices they
controlled both houses of legislature so
there was no real great rivalry with
Republicans except perhaps at the
general election and so usually that
produces intra-party competition and so
that's a long way of saying that Jess
was critically important and some other
people in the state legislature George
Miller power in the state Senate but
especially Jess was critically important
in the early successes later had a
brutal falling-out with Pat yeah I guess
I have two questions one you're talking
about unruly bring has leads me to ask
do you think the imposition of term
limits have had any impact upon the
political philosophies that we see and
secondly you know would appear to me and
disagree please if you do that we see in
California our bluntly our
infrastructure going to pot to seed in a
number of areas from highways to
universities and I would like to think
that at some time the electorate will
wake up and realize investment is once
again needed and then maybe the wheel
will have turned 360 degrees and I'd
like your opinion on that as well thank
you sure
I think term limits have had a great
impact a great effect and it's been
generally a bad effect in my view in
politics as in most things in life
experience and practice are useful and
limiting people to very very short
periods in office and the term limits in
California are really very short means
that you end up with legislators who
have less experience less knowledge less
long-term perspective and that's very
very damaging and so I do think that I'm
generally not one who believes that the
successes of Pat's era were due to the
fact that people were then geniuses and
now they're morons or something like
that but I do think that term limits is
a structural change that has really
harmed the legislature is infrastructure
going to pot yes there's no question of
that and again it reflects I think the
fact that we have failed to invest in
infrastructure in the state the
comparison I always use in that is that
when Pat was governor in those eight
years the university state built three
University of California campuses from
scratch UC San Diego UC Irvine and UC
Santa Cruz it's been 40 years since he
left the governor's office and we are
only now opening one more campus the new
campus at Merced that's going to open in
about three weeks or so and you could
sort of
make that analogy with regard to
investment in a wide variety of public
areas in the last 40 years so yes I
think we need to return to that sort of
feeling of investment in public
infrastructure but again to do that we
need to begin to articulate the idea
that government can do some things right
because if we believe and say that
government is constantly a failure and a
waste of money nobody's going to want to
invest in it yeah I just haven't at a
similar to yours and that's 40 years of
a attack by the Conservatives I arrived
in this state as a marine in 1958 the
same year Pat Brown was elected governor
and it was so optimistic at the time
everybody felt we were just gonna climb
forever and then something happened in
the early 60s radio talk shows started
to get popular and they're invariably
all right wing television Joe Pyne show
at the time all attacking the New Deal
liberals and I think this has had a
dramatic effect if you wouldn't follow
this state like Proposition 13 it did
help people in some cases but really our
decline our educational system started
at that point we just couldn't fund the
system any longer because we just took
so much money out of the system so I
think eventually if you look at our
deficits in the state and our federal
deficits I think I I pray if the
American people are going to wake up and
see what's happening because I think we
had something very optimistic and I
think we should get back there yeah III
would agree with that I think that
there's no question that the the rise of
the modern conservative movement which
coincided with Pat's the end of Pat's
career has made a profound difference
not just in politics but in public
policy across the country and in my view
has dragged the political spectrum too
far to the right and so I would
essentially agree with you I do I should
say by the way that I don't think
although I think the general atmosphere
was optimistic I don't think that
politics was necessarily nicer than and
I think it's important that we think
about that and understand that because
there is an argument that the
accomplishments of Pat's you're arrested
not on ideology or on political belief
but on the fact that everybody got along
politically and I think that's not an
accurate picture historically and I
think it's it undermines the idea that
we should move back toward the beliefs
of the New Deal consensus the example I
always use is right here in San
Francisco in 1964 as some of you will
remember the Republican National
Convention was held in San Francisco at
the Cow Palace Barry Goldwater was the
nominee of course in his acceptance
speech he said quite famously extremism
in the defense of Liberty is no vice a
controversial phrase then as now the
next day reporters went to Pat he was
the the governor of the host state
obviously was not a Republican and was
not at the convention but he was the
governor of the host state so they went
to Pat and they said what do you think
about senator goldwater's acceptance
speech and he said quote the stench of
fascism is in the air now I I cannot
tell you anything said by any sitting
governor last year not move on not Swift
Boat Veterans but any sitting governor
last year that's that harsh about John
Kerry or George Bush so I do think it's
important to remember that politics then
as now was a full-contact sport it was
aggressive you took on your opponents it
was not a case of everybody getting
around and holding hands and singing
Kumbaya that's not why the
accomplishments of Pat Brown's era were
so manifest they were manifest because
Pat and those around him articulated the
idea that government could solve
problems yeah there have been a few
mentions of jets Unruh and that brought
to mind that probably for most of us who
were in California in the 50s and 60s
even if skids
recall him as Big Daddy in the late 50s
and early 60s and then by the spring of
1968 during the Democratic primary there
was something of a metamorphosis it
seemed in speaker Unruh and I wondered
was Governor Brown perhaps just a little
bit too old or just too much of a big
government person to I've ever even
dabbled in anything like that was there
any sort of crisis of confidence in his
own mind about why is it that my son and
all of that generation seem to be
turning against us well there were there
were Pat had crises of confidence at
times not so much really about the
change in ideology or the change or the
rise the modern conservative movement
but he certainly there were there were
moments when he would have a crisis of
confidence one of the interesting things
about Pat is that he never went to
college he got out of high school and
decided to enroll in law school you
could then go to law school without
having a bachelor's degree so he went to
San Francisco School of Law graduated
became a lawyer moved forward in his
career and so forth but he never
graduated from college and he talked in
his oral history in his retirement about
the fact that that would make him at
times sort of insecure and uncertain
around people who were better educated
he would talk about being worried about
mispronouncing words things like that so
there were times when Pat's confidence
buckled a little bit I think because of
sort of his own experiences and his own
personality he in 1962 when Richard
Nixon announced he was going to run for
governor Nixon had of course come within
a hair's breadth of winning the
presidency Pat told Bernice his wife
that he was thinking about not running
for governor not running for reelection
so there were moments when he certainly
had a crisis of confidence I don't think
he really had a crisis of confidence
with regard to the idea that the modern
conservative movement might might be
right he didn't ever really have a
crisis of confidence and think boy maybe
Reagan's right
maybe FDR was wrong all along those were
core beliefs that that were a little too
deep to be shaken in his retirement he
used to the this will give you an idea
of the conviction of his belief that
Ronald Reagan was wrong and also his
sense of humor in his retirement if he
needed to go to the bathroom he would
announce I have to cast a vote for
Ronald Reagan that gives you a sense of
his core belief that that Reagan was
wrong and I don't think he had a crisis
about that yes I know this talk is not
about his son Jerry but okay I have a
question about that
ion I can I can I can understand why
Willie Brown went from the state
legislature to become mayor of San
Francisco but I could never under quite
understand why Jerry Brown decided to
become wanted to be mayor of Oakland
after being governor of the state to me
it seems like a comedown
and do you think this was because he had
no illusions about getting into any
higher office such as it some spot in
Washington or you know I
III would leave that to Jerry if he were
here I I'd be happy to ask him I should
say by the way that two of Pat's
daughters are here Barbara and Cynthia
are here you want to say why your
brother wanted to be governor or mayor
of Oakland you don't to wade into that
do you
IIIi don't know why Jerry wanted to be
mayor of Oakland I don't know why he
wants to be Attorney General but he can
run for whatever he likes yes a comment
on the University of California I do not
agree with this running it down it is
one of the greatest universities in the
world and in last October a worldwide
survey was made of the universities and
colleges of the world and the top 200
were published in the league table and
seven of the nine california campuses
are in the first 200 in the world and
that to me is a tremendous achievement
yeah I don't think I was i I don't think
I intended anyway to run down the
University of California I think in fact
one of the things I've been talking
about is the fact that the state has
failed to invest in its sufficiently in
its system of public Irish
so I don't disagree with anything you
said and I certainly didn't intend to
run down you see yeah I understand the
last question so anyway regardless of
what your political affiliation is a
male or female governor would have to
keep his or her eye on Washington all
the time in terms of legislative things
affecting the state federal grants
matching funds resources natural
resources in your research what did Pat
do about Washington I don't have any
history myself and I wasn't here but did
he ignore it did did he work with it did
he leverage it did he play it I mean
what could you have some history on that
please sure there are two ways in which
I guess he interacted with Washington in
the political sense he certainly was
aware that Washington and the federal
government played a critical role in
influencing what states do and what
happens in states he actually opened the
first California office in Washington so
the the the state for the first time had
a full-time paying representative a
lobbyist if you will in Washington so he
was certainly aware of that the other
way in which he interacted in Washington
which is quite common to California
governor's is that he dreamed of being
president in 1959 after he was elected
and experienced a great first term in
office all sorts of achievements people
were saying it was the greatest
legislative session since Hiram Johnson
60 years before Pat got a little bit of
presidential fever about 1960 and began
to organize a sort of nascent campaign
certainly never said he was running for
president but began to send a couple of
people around the country to feel out
the idea that he might run for president
in 1960 he was stuck with the fact that
in 58 while running for governor he had
promised to serve a full term and not to
run for president and candidly switched
180 degrees on that and announced on
thinking about it further I just decided
that's not very patriotic and admitted
that he was contemplating the idea of
running for
president it was never really gonna go
anywhere and it fell apart and he never
really had the opportunity to run for
president again but so he kept an eye on
Washington I suppose both in policy
terms and in political terms he would
love to have been a national figure in
fact I talk in the book about a
telephone conversation with Lyndon
Johnson in 1964 when Lyndon Johnson was
trying to pick his vice-presidential
running mate in the 64 election of
course there there had been no vice
president since Johnson had become
president and Pat was being bandied
around as a potential vice presidential
nominee and Pat loved the idea would
have loved to have been vice president
he got a call shortly before the
convention Democratic convention that
year was going to be in Atlantic City
and he got a call from Johnson and this
call was taped as a lot of Johnson's
phone calls were taped so you can go to
the Johnson library in Texas and listen
to it Pat got a call from Johnson and
thought to himself he talked about this
later thought to himself this might be
the call I he might be about to ask me
to be the vice presidential nominee
Johnson began by saying you've done a
great job out there in California you're
the one of the greatest governors in the
country you're the guy I look to in
California Pat sort of getting higher
and higher by the moment Johnson said so
there's really something I want you to
do for me
Pat thought I'm within half a sentence
of being on the national ticket and
Johnson said I want you to introduce me
to Atlantic City well Pat knew that he
wouldn't ask the vice presidential
nominee to nominate the presidential
candidate so the air went out of Pat's
balloon and that was it and that was I
suppose the end of Pat's and